congratulations the big night is finally
here how you feeling very very good this
is fantastic it's quite the turnout it's
a lot of people it's pretty awesome
you're shutting down hollywood boulevard
we are we are as a marvel you know
disney they know how to do it don't they
we throw a party and do it properly you
know thor is look at that everyone's
screaming for you
maybe someone behind me oh there's
someone special behind you over there
there he is see i knew that he won i
felt it
that was like very special and made you
want to come back again obviously a
contractual obligation that's my
you're the man behind why we see this
man in the buff
in the buff oh yeah you took my pants
off didn't you uh yeah yeah yeah
he didn't even know we were shooting in
the movie
you didn't even know there were cameras
when it wasn't like a weird like
rehearsal process yeah i said all right
i'm down
heading into that scene when training
yeah yeah pretty sad
yeah it's going well my career mainly
but
heading into that scene training did you
have to do extra squats or anything like
that oh it was a lot of work yeah i mean
it was kind of
10 11 years into making that shot we
each each film we've taken off another
item of clothing and now we just kind of
took it all off and
that was all he's doing i hear love
thunder and booty
love thunder and booty we're gonna
re-title the film now based on love
thunder booty
now thor is a god amongst the men but
would you say his biggest weakness in
this film is his ex-girlfriend sure i
mean is it a is it a weakness or a
strength you know we'll have to see the
film and find out but she certainly
brings out something uh
very important in him now really quickly
we talked to tessa thompson earlier this
week and she said that luke was the
funniest hemsworth brother what do you
have to say about that i'd agree i'd
agree yeah you should hurry up this
interview and get him into this he
already went by
tonight does that mean a lot absolutely
yeah liam's in uh in europe somewhere
shooting a movie so but i've got luke
[Music]
you